nach der rücktrittsankündigung von kramp
karrenbauer cdu politiker fordern einen
zügigen führungswechsel neuer
geheimdienst skandal der
bundesnachrichtendienst und die ci haben
jahrzehnte lang auch befreundete staaten
ausgespäht und noch ein rücktritt nach
gerade mal elf wochen schmeißt härter
trainer klinsmann überraschend das
handtuch
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen an
diesem dienstag den 11
februar hat die nachrichten vom sport
hat heute norbert könig für sie dabei
guten abend in der cdu brodelt es nach
dem angekündigten rückzug ihrer
parteichefin der weg den
kramp-karrenbauer zur lösung der
führungskrise vorgeschlagen hat
empfinden viele in der union als viel zu
langwierig sie fordern auf jetzt schnell
einen nachfolger oder eine nachfolgerin
zu bestimmen geht es nach annegret kramp
karrenbauer lässt sich die cdu mit der
suche nach einem kanzlerkandidaten oder
eine kandidatin zeit er oder sie würde
erst auf einem parteitag im dezember
gekürt und dann gleichzeitig den vorsitz
übernehmen zu spät findet er ein oder
die andere weniger
noch ist die parteichefin
doch schon am tag eins nach der
rückzugsankündigung ist fraglich ob
annegret kramp karrenbauer ihren
nachfolgeplan so durchsetzen kann die
gedacht erst im winter über
parteivorsitz und kanzlerkandidatur
entscheiden zu lassen erst mal ist ja
parteitag für den dezember angesetzt das
ist jetzt erst mal der plan wenn es sich
unterwegs er ändert wir sind zwar
konservativ aber auch flexibel da müssen
wir einfach schauen wo die reise hingeht
die csu hat das schon für sich
entschieden und zwar anders entschieden
es gibt eine offene führungsfrage die
muss geklärt werden und die muss auch
schnell geklärt werden ein zeitraum über
mehrere monate bei der findung von
personalfragen die scheint mir abwegig
zu sein
beim letzten mal hatten die kandidaten
sich auf regionalkonferenzen vorgestellt
gewählt wurde dann auf einem parteitag
auf dem kramp karrenbauer sich
durchsetzte wiederholung dieses
verfahrens fraglich also ich glaube es
kann nicht von oben her entschieden
werden sondern die partei muss das
tragen die partei macht ja auch
wahlkampf
ich meine vom zeitplan her dass das vor
der sommerpause entschieden sein muss
ich war und bin für eine
mitgliederentscheidung
das aber hat der letzte parteitag
ausgeschlossen mancher hofft dass es zu
einer einigung unter den aspiranten
selbst kommt ich würde mich freuen wenn
man sich in anführungsstrichen gütlich
geeinigt eine person auf stellt die
versöhnt aber gleichzeitig führung zeigt
und in einem team verankert ist was die
breite einer volkspartei ausdruck
fahrplan also umstritten machtkampf
nicht ausgeschlossen
von inhaltlichen fragen wohin die union
steuern soll ganz zu schweigen
fragen an theo koll in berlin hat
annegret kramp karrenbauer dennoch die
kraft und die autorität den prozess der
kandidatenauswahl zu steuern
also ehrlich zu sein ich glaube nein und
ihr einfluss dürfte auch mit jedem tag
weiter schwinden
führende cdu leute und auch die
schwesterpartei csu haben das ja heute
überdeutlich gemacht indem sie die
vorgeschlagene klärung des ende des
jahres schlichtweg als abwegig
beschrieben haben aber selbst wenn die
nachfolge schnell entschieden würde dann
steuert die cdu mit volldampf für die
nächste krise denn solange frau merkel
kanzlerin ist bleibt der cdu vorsitz
relativ machtlos die partei hat also
aktuell die wahl zwischen zwei übeln ein
quälend langer auswahlprozess oder ein
schnell gewählter neuer vorsitzender der
dann aber sehr lange dasselbe problem
hat dass frau kramp karrenbauer hatte
dass es da eine kanzlerin gibt die die
wirkliche macht hat in der frage wie
weiter cdu geht es ja auch um die
abgrenzung zur afg und da hat sich ja
heute die kanzlerin sehr deutlich
geäußert
frau merkel ist ganz offensichtlich bei
wenigem so entschieden wie bei der
warnung vor der afg sie hat heute so ist
aus der fraktionssitzung zu hören die
afg scharf attackiert und ihr
vorgeworfen sie wolle die demokratie
untergraben
auch deshalb müssen sich die cdu klar
von der afg abgrenzen denn die wolle die
demokratie zerstören das sind
ungewöhnlich deutliche worte für merkel
und sie passen zu ihrem unverzeihlich
mit dem sie schon die vorgänger in
thüringen kommentiert hat vielen dank
nach berlin
gesucht wurde in berlin ja auch ein
neuer ostbeauftragte der bundesregierung
und der ist nun gefunden
es ist marco wanderwitz ein sachse
bisher staatssekretär im
bundesinnenministerium wanderwitz folgt
auf christian hirte den die kanzlerin
nach dessen freudigem tweet zur
ministerpräsidentenwahl in thüringen für
nicht mehr tragbar gehalten hatte und
jetzt zu einer hoch umstrittenen
geheimdienst missionen mit gewaltigem
ausmaß operationen rubicon der deutsche
bundesnachrichtendienst und die
amerikanische sie haben jahrzehntelang
mehr als 100 länder ausspioniert das
zeigen recherchen des zdf der washington
post und des schweizer fernsehens bnd
und c hatten heimlich die schweizer
firma crypto ag erworben
über sie verkauften see
kommunikationstechnik die aber war
manipuliert die käufer wurden abgehört
die kunden waren etwa regierungen und
geheimdienste im nahen und mittleren
osten in afrika in südamerika in fernost
aber auch in europa darunter
nato-partner mehr von florian a
als 2013 bekannt wird dass der us
geheimdienst nsa angela merkels handy
abhört reagiert die kanzlerin öffentlich
empört ausgehen unter freunden das geht
dann recherchen von zdf washington post
und schweizer rundfunk aber zeigen
lange war das abhören engster freunde
auch deutsche praxis mit der operation
rubicon eine der größten abhöraktionen
der geschichte von bnd und ca im zentrum
der aktionen die schweizer crypto ag
weltmarktführer für
verschlüsselungstechnik 1970 kaufen cia
und bnd die firma über treuhänder
verschleiert mit aktiver mithilfe des
siemens-konzerns fortan lassen bnd und
chl die verschlüsselungs geräte heimlich
manipulieren so dass die
nachrichtendienste geheime kommunikation
mithören können auch bei engsten
vertrauten eu und nato partnern
evra handel kann über 100 staaten zeiten
milliarden dollar dafür dass ihnen ihre
staatsgeheimnisse gestohlen wurden das
war schon ziemlich dreist sein freund
schicken was der bnd so erfährt ist
brisant etwa aus argentinien
mehr als 30.000 menschen fördern dem
argentinischen militärregime ende der
70er anfang der 80er jahre zum opfer die
deutsche regierung unter kanzler helmut
schmidt weiß dank der apo operation sehr
früh über folter und tötungen bescheid
doch sie schweigt das ist eine ein
verbrechen was dort gemacht worden ist
man hätte diese folterpraktiken diese
tötungs praktiken diese kriegs praktiken
hätte man versuchen müssen zu verhindern
der frühere kanzleramtsminister
schmidbauer hingegen rechtfertigt die
abhöraktion und bestätigt sie nebenbei
die aktion rubicon hat sicher dazu
beigetragen dass die welt ein stück
sicherer geblieben ist angenehmer
nebeneffekt der bnd verdient millionen
über die beteiligung in der krypta ag
ohne wissen des bundestags 1993 statt
der bnd aus rubicon aus fragen bleiben
auf die die grüne opposition antworten
verlangt schon morgen im
parlamentarischen kontrollgremium des
bundestags
ausführlich berichtet frontal 21 über
das ausspäh programm heute um 21 uhr
und genau nachlesen wie bmw und fiat mit
der operation rubicon alle täuschten
können sie auf heute.de und noch ein
überraschender rückzug in dieser woche
kardinal reinhard marx gibt den vorsitz
der bischofskonferenz ab zur wahl anfang
märz wird er nicht mehr antreten
am ende einer möglichen zweiten amtszeit
wäre er 72 jahre alt so die begründung
es sollten jetzt aber die jüngeren an
die reihe kommen über den unerwarteten
schritt und die reaktion sibylle bassler
alles habe seine zeit sagt kardinal
reinhard marx deshalb trete er nicht für
eine zweite amtszeit als vorsitzender
der deutschen bischofskonferenz
in einem brief an die deutschen bischöfe
teil der 66-jährige mit ich finde es
sollte die jüngere generation an die
reihe kommen und vielleicht ist es auch
gut wenn es häufiger einen wechsel in
dieser aufgabe gibt verzicht aus
altersgründen für viele kommt diese
nachricht überraschend denn kardinal
marx gilt als aufklärer er hat steht
klare worte gefunden gerade auch bei der
aufarbeitung des missbrauchsskandals
allzu lange haben wir die kirche wird
geschaut vertuscht geleugnet wollten es
nicht als reaktion auf den
missbrauchsskandal hat er den synodalen
weg den reformprozess der katholischen
kirche in deutschland mit initiiert
gemeinsam mit katholischen laien wird in
den nächsten jahren und positionen zur
sexualmoral der kirche zur stellung der
frau und zum zölibat gerungen
durch den rückzug von marx befürchten
vertreter der basis nun einen
rückschritt
gerade wo jetzt die synodale weg in
deutschland begonnen hat wirklich ein
reformprozess der weltweit beachtung
findet da wäre es gut wenn dieser
reformprozess durch diesen rücktritt
nicht gefährdet ist andere wiederum
sehen in seinem verzicht auf das amt als
vorsitzender auch eine chance er wird
sich jetzt noch freier und klarer
einbringen können in diesen synodalen
prozess so dass es am ende vielleicht
sogar ein gewinn sein könnte dass
kardinal marx auch weiterhin beim
reformprozess aktiv sein wird eine
hoffnung die heute viele teil
im kampf gegen das corona virus könnte
ein erster impfstoff in 18 monaten
verfügbar sein
das hat die weltgesundheitsorganisation
bekannt gegeben
das virus sei eine ernsthafte bedrohung
für die welt in genf beraten bis morgen
400 internationale experten darüber wie
man tests medikamente und
therapiemethoden schneller entwickeln
kann
mittlerweile gibt es in china mehr als
1000 bestätigte todesfälle am hellichten
tag war im august 2009 10 ein georgier
im berliner tiergarten erschossen worden
ein mordfall der heftige spannungen
ausgelöst hatte zwischen deutschland und
russland
heute wurde der tatverdächtige nach
karlsruhe zum bundesgerichtshof gebracht
gegen war sind gibt es einen neuen
haftbefehl
der russische staatsbürger soll in
berlin auf den 40 jährigen georgier
geschossen haben und zwar im auftrag
russischer stellen so vermuten die
deutschen behörden
käufer von e autos werden auf diese
nachricht gewartet haben die höheren
prämien sind genehmigt die eu kommission
in brüssel gab grünes licht teilte das
wirtschaftsministerium mit je nach
kaufpreis gibt es jetzt bis zu 6000 euro
für alle fahrzeuge die nach dem vierten
november zugelassen wurden
das hört man bestimmt auch in stuttgart
gerne dort musste der daimler konzern
heute nämlich einen herben
gewinneinbruch präsentieren hatte sich
daimler im jahr 2017 noch über ein plus
von 10,6 milliarden euro freuen können
ging der gewinn 2018 schon um 29 prozent
auf 7,6 milliarden euro zurück
im vergangenen jahr blieben mit 2,7
milliarden sogar 64 prozent weniger als
im vorjahr wo es derzeit hakt und was
sich ändern soll zeigt sein klasse
als es im saal noch dunkel ist erfahren
sie per video schon ihre
zukunftsvisionen aber visionen die
elektrisch sind die zeigen sollen
daimler hat mit dem umbruch begonnen weg
von verbrenner hin zur neuen marschroute
electric forst das ist sicherlich die
größte investition größtes
investitionsvorhaben was wir jetzt haben
und da werden wir in den nächsten paar
jahren hier massiv hochform
milliardeninvestitionen in
elektromobilität werden nötig sein
in zeiten in denen daimler gleichzeitig
milliarden für die noch lange nicht
ausgestanden
diese krise bereithalten muss beides
diesen rücklagen und hohe investitionen
in das elektrische fahren sind auch
hauptverantwortlich dafür dass die
daimler gewinne zuletzt massiv
eingebrochen sind
die finanziellen ergebnisse die wir
präsentieren für das jahr 2009 10 das
zählt nicht
ergebnisse die wir für die zukunft sehen
wollen
das reicht nicht ein drastisches
sparprogramm soll nun helfen die kosten
zu senken
unter anderem werden arbeitsplätze
wegfallen gerüchten zufolge bis zu
15.000 außerdem wollen sie nicht
profitable fahrzeugmodelle aussortieren
ist es richtig dass man sich vielmehr
mit zukunftsthemen beschäftigt als wir
das bisher getan hat in bezug auf e
mobilität läuft daher schon gefahr
einfach nicht mehr zur ersten liga zu
gehören ich hätte mir gewünscht dass
daimler in sachen elektromobilität
schneller sein würde
wir haben alle die sorge dass die co2
ziele nicht erreicht werden können das
hat neue strafzahlungen zur folge
nur mit mehr elektroautos werden co2
strafen von der eu zu verhindern sein
daimler muss also investieren und
gleichzeitig sparen ein schwieriger
spagat
in deutschland ist der sturm sabine
immer noch ein thema mancherorts haben
die ausläufer mehr schaden angerichtet
als das orkantief selbst in
niedersachsen wurde eine frau mit ihrem
einkaufstrolley von einer böe auf die
straße gezogen und tödlich verletzt und
es gibt jede menge umgestürzte bäume
kaputte dächer und im norden viel wasser
florian kojak mit einem überblick
für den fahrer dieses wagens heißt die
letzte rettung abschleppdienst
zu schnell druck der wind das wasser in
den hamburger hafen in diesen minuten
erreicht die sturmflut ihren höhepunkt
für die meisten anwohner grund genug
sich nach drinnen zu verziehen
doch einige kommen trotzdem gerade wegen
der wetterkapriolen schon beeindruckend
wie schnell das geht dass ich nie
gedacht ich hätte gedacht das dauert
länger bis es hier aufläuft in barocker
sind schon am nachmittag weitere teile
des strands abgebrochen
die tourismusbranche schlägt schon jetzt
alarm denn ohne strand gibt es keine
strandkörbe und damit weniger touristen
entwarnung dagegen bei der bahn die züge
fahren wieder weitgehend nach plan nur
einige regionalverbindungen sind noch
unterbrochen
auch an den deutschen flughäfen hat sich
die lage entspannt in münchen fielen
trotzdem noch knapp 100 flüge aus auch
weil einige maschinen und crews noch
nicht wieder an ort und stelle sind
die rettungskräfte haben in ganz
deutschland weiter ordentlich zu tun vor
allem wegen umgestürzter bäume wie hier
in abensberg in niederbayern und es
bleibt stürmisch vor allem für die
mittelgebirge sind in den kommenden
stunden kräftige schauer und schnee
regen vorhergesagt
und noch ein rückschritt und zwar in der
fußball-bundesliga hat jürgen klinsmann
den trainerposten bei hertha bsc geräumt
das war auch nicht ziemlich
überraschungen arbeit oder ja also ich
denke nach nur elf wochen abends zeit
hat wohl kaum jemand damit gerechnet es
herrscht allenthalben ratlosigkeit die
ambitionierten pläne des trainers jürgen
klinsmann mit hertha bsc sind makulatur
drei tage nach der heimpleite gegen
mainz wird der 55 jährige das handtuch
überraschung beim vormittagstraining in
berlin chef trainer jürgen klinsmann
nicht mehr da alexander nouri gibt die
kommandos die mannschaft erst am morgen
informiert und überrascht wir hatten
heute morgen ein treffen im
besprechungsraum wir dachten es wäre die
normale nachbesprechung nach dem mainz
spiel aber es war etwas anderes jürgen
sagte uns dass er nicht länger unser
trainer ist entgegen erster meldungen
auch investor lars windhorst erst heute
morgen von klinsmann unterrichtet über
die sozialen medien beklagt klinsmann
derweil fehlende rückendeckung gerade im
abstiegskampf sind einheit zusammenhalt
und konzentration auf das wesentliche
die wichtigsten
minte sind sie nicht garantiert kann ich
mein potenzial als trainer nicht
ausschöpfen
stürmische zeiten in berlin klinsmann
bleibt das aufsichtsrat an bord an der
seitenlinie richten soll es bis auf
weiteres sein co-trainer alexander nouri
thomas skulski beobachtet für uns die
situation in berlin thomas was steckt
hinter den eher vage formulierten
rücktritts gründen von jürgen klinsmann
das ist sicherlich ein großer ego trip
von jürgen klinsmann der ihn nun zurück
nach kalifornien führt für die
verantwortlichen hier bei hertha bsc ist
es ein schlag aus dem nichts mitten ins
gesicht waren sie doch quasi bis heute
morgen davon ausgegangen dass klinsmann
durchaus bereit wäre
über den sommer hinaus trainer von
hertha bsc zu bleiben allerdings hatte
er dafür mehr geld und mehr macht
eingefordert etwa im stile eines
teammanagers in england in der premier
league ein wunsch der nicht erfüllt
wurde und nun offensichtlich zu dieser
reaktion geführt hatte fakt ist das
projekt big city club droht zur großen
lachnummer von berlin zu werden der
zweite nach dem br draußen in schönefeld
thomas kurz geologie stadion vielen dank
frühstart für sebastian vettel und den
formel 1 rennstall von ferrari als
erstes team haben die italiener im
altehrwürdigen theater romolo wally in
reggio emilia dass 2020 2020 modell
namens sf 1000 vorgestellt der klare
auftrag für vettel und seinen kollegen
charlie claire endlich wieder den titel
für die roten holen
darauf warten wir ferraristi jetzt schon
13 jahre 13 jahre bringt vielleicht
glück ziemlich futuristisch aus windig
und glatt stars in die stichworte für
das wetter der nacht wechselhaft geht es
aber auch morgen weiter über tag mehr
dazu gleich von katja horneffer das war
es von uns wir danken für ihr interesse
verweisen gerne auf das heute journal
mit claus kleber um 21 uhr 45 und
wünschen einen ruhigen gemütlichen amt
morgen freut sich barbara hahlweg auf
sie
[Musik]
meine damen und herren orkantief sabine
hat mit seinem zentrum bereits finnland
erreicht dahinter gibt es kleine
namenlose thies die aber durchaus auch
noch kräftigen sturm dabei haben und
kühle luft deswegen erwarten wir in
dieser nacht eben nicht nur stumm und
eine sturmflut an der nordsee sondern
auch gefährlich glatte straßen denn es
gibt häufig schneeschauer mit
schneeverwehungen müssen wir auch noch
rechnen in den mittelgebirgen
denn die temperatur und die sinken auf
werte zwischen plus 3 und minus zwei
grad und nur auf den ostfriesischen
inseln bleibt ist ein kleines bisschen
milder
die höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 1 grad am alpenrand und 9 grad
am oberrhein und das wetter bleibt
extrem abwechslungsreich immer wieder
gibt es kräftige schnee regen regen und
schneeschauer sind auch kurze gewitter
dabei am freundlichsten wird es wohl
noch im nordosten und es bleibt bei
diesem starken bis stürmischen wind aus
westlichen richtungen
deswegen droht auch morgen noch mal eine
sturmflut an der nordsee in den nächsten
tagen geht es wechselhaft weiter aber
bleibt es glatt am donnerstag der
freitag wird ein bisschen ruhiger und
der samstag dann merklich milder
schönen abend noch